Il paraît que la saucisse
au foie rancit en une nuit...
Si c'est le cas,
on ne le dirait absolument pas
au goût.
Qui êtes-vous ?
- Bonjour, Archie.
- Salut, fillette.
Tu connais ce type ?
Sergent Archie Sparks,
voici... Dick.
- Vic. Vic Towbridge.
- Salut, Vic.
T'as appelé ce gars hier soir,
quand j'étais sous la douche ?
Archie, je vous ai appelé
hier soir ?
Non, fillette.
Comme à votre habitude,
vous vous êtes bien fait désirer.
Bien.
Qu'il n'y ait pas de malentendu.
- Qui êtes-vous ?
- Police Militaire.
Unité spéciale de recherche
de déserteurs.
Meredith Cole.
Sur le point d'être appréhendée.
- Tu es soldat ?
- Habillez-vous, caporal.
Oui, sergent.
Chéri, Vic...
Tu voudrais nous faire du café ?
Du café ?
Va te faire foutre.
C'est ce que j'ai fait hier,
pendant que tu te douchais.
Je ferais mieux de me rhabiller.
Bonne idée.
- Elle vous a ramassé où ?
- C'est moi qui l'ai draguée.
C'est la nouvelle serveuse
de chez Amidson's.
C'est mal fréquenté.
Elle voulait que je la raccompagne.
Elle est maligne.
Elle savait que je la cherchais
et elle n'avait pas d'endroit où dormir.
Pourquoi elle a déserté ?
Le réveillon de Noël
Merci de m'avoir dépannée.
C'est rien.
J'espère que ton père va guérir.
Oui. Passez un bon Noël.
Ce haut-parleur aurait
déjà dû être réparé.
Ce n'est pas parce que c'est Noël,
qu'il faut traîner.
Danny. Joyeux Noël.
Pour moi, Noël,
c'est dans 9 heures.
Il y en a qui prennent leur travail
au sérieux.
Eteignez ça !
J'ai une nouvelle pour vous.
Ce n'est pas un motel ici.
Juste un petit dernier
pour la route, capitaine.
Il y a ça aussi.
Ce n'est pas que vous le méritiez.
Une petite prime pour Noël.
Comprendre ?
C'est votre prime pour Noël.
Vous croyez que je vous vole ?
Vous voulez un billet ?
Ça y est, j'y suis presque.
Ça va, ça ?
Là, c'est ça.
Vous avez du papier cadeau
ou du ruban ?
Vous savez, ce genre de truc ?
Et une carte de Noël.
Salut, Polly. Ton café est meilleur
qu'hier, j'espère ?
J'en prends un, de toute façon.
Avis à tous les passagers.
Le car à destination d'El Paso,
Deming, Lordsburg
et Tucson est prêt à partir.
Non, chérie, je te le promets.
Je serai là avant ton réveil.
Dis-lui à Dorothée
de s'en occuper.
Elle a raison.
Pas de glace au dîner.
Chérie ?
Bordel !
Foutue bagnole !
Tas de ferraille !
- Hé mec...
- Attendez votre tour.
Ce car s'enfonce dans le Texas profond
ou il va jusqu'à la frontière ?
- Les infos, c'est au guichet.
- Mec. Je t'ai dit...
Putain de Texas !
Trésor ? Quoi ?
Non, il ne peut pas t'apporter
de chien, le Père Noël.
On en a déjà un.
Je sais qu'il sent mauvais.
Parfois les chiens mâles
ont une odeur forte.
Attendez !
Je te rappelle plus tard.
Je t'adore.
- De justesse.
- C'est une habitude chez moi.
Voilà. C'est parti.
Mesdames, messieurs,
bienvenus à bord.
Je m'appelle Daniel Gunn.
Je serai votre conducteur
jusqu'à Tucson.
Prochain arrêt, Picadillo au Texas.
A six heures d'ici.
Vous n'avez qu'à vous détendre
et vous passerez un bon réveillon.
- Oui, ça sent bon.
- Tenez.
C'est notre ligne "Elégance".
Lavande ?
Ça va, s'il se douche
dès l'arrivée à l'hôtel.
Mais s'il doit attendre
jusqu'au matin,
il faut quelque chose de plus...
- Poivré ?
- C'est ça.
C'est pour ça, qu'on a créé
"Poudre d'or".
Intéressant...
Oui, c'est chouette.
C'est pour mon fils, Stevie.
C'est un bon cadeau de Noël.
Vous trouvez l'idée bizarre ?
Non, je trouve
que vous avez fait vite.
C'est vrai.
Je suis toujours en retard et...
Vous avez acheté des piles
au moins ?
Du moment que le jouet fonctionne,
le reste n'est pas important.
- C'est elle ?
- Oui.
Elle est montée dans le bus
une heure avant l'alerte.
L'armée se donne autant de mal
pour ce genre de gens ?
Non, la plupart se rendent.
Eux, ils se font arrêter
pour des bêtises.
Brûler un feu rouge...
Voler dans un magasin.
- Et votre Cendrillon ?
- Son grand-père est sénateur.
- Ce n'est pas cool.
- Si on ne la retrouve pas, oui.
Il était vétéran ?
- Quatre fois médaillé.
- La Brigade à Dick Cheney.
- Pourquoi elle s'est enfuie ?
- C'est important ?
Vous savez...
C'est le réveillon de Noël.
Vous vous en donnez du mal
pour cette fillette.
- Je déteste la bûche.
- Moi aussi.
Mais c'est triste de passer
le réveillon tout seul.
Vous êtes en permission
depuis longtemps ?
- Pardon ?
- Vos chaussures.
- Vous étiez en Irak ?
- Vous croyez que je suis soldat ?
Où ça en Irak ?
Vous êtes dans l'armée ou quoi ?
Section des conducteurs
internationaux. 9 mois à Bagdad.
- Vous appelez, on est là.
- Vous avez fait les douze ?
C'est quoi, "les douze" ?
Les douze km jusqu'à l'aéroport.
Le tronçon de route
le plus dangereux du monde.
Là-bas, le conducteur du car,
c'est "Mad Max".
Accrochez-vous !
Ça va aller.
- Vous avez vu leur badge ?
- Leur badge ?
L'insigne de leur gang.
- Je n'ai rien vu.
- Des hors-la-loi ? Cool !
Des hors-la-loi ?
Non. C'est des "Nomades".
C'est quoi des nomades ?
- Des suppôts de Satan.
- Ils ont fait demi-tour ?
Non.
Ça va aller.
Le coup a été rude,
mais ça va aller.
- Plus de soucis à se faire.
- Faites gaffe !
Arrêtez le car !
Freinez !
Vous les avez écrasés !
Vous deux, venez avec moi.
Les autres, restez ici !
J'entraîne une équipe de foot,
je suis secouriste.
Allez voir l'autre.
Je n'ai pas de réseau.
Quelqu'un en a ?
Aucun signal.
Neuf mois en Irak.
J'en ai perdu des amis.
Dire que j'ai survécu.
Ça va aller.
On va chercher de l'aide.
Lâche cette arme !
Il faut y aller !
Les clés ?
Il a pris les clés !
Duke ! Il revient !
Putain !
Salopard !
C'est bon, allons-y !
Ça va ?
Mon Dieu ! Faites vite !
- Qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire ?
- Appuyez dessus !
Où sont les clés ?
Non !
Il vaut mieux remonter
dans le car.
On s'en va.
Vite !
Dépêchez-vous !
Accrochez-vous !
Il faut attendre Duke.
Ça démarre pas !
Appuie !
Attendez !
C'est un vrai salopard,
mais il faut qu'on l'attende.
On ne l'attendra pas !
- Dieu merci.
- Bébé.
On en parlera tout à l'heure.
Ils arrivent !
- C'est quoi, votre nom ?
- Walter Lindley.
Lindley. Vous conduisez
20 tonnes d'acier. Utilisez-les !
Mon Dieu...
Est-ce que vous avez
des pansements ?
Non !
- On n'en a plus besoin.
- Moi, si.
Il faut stopper l'hémorragie.
Quelqu'un a du tissu
ou des gazes ?
C'est superficiel.
La balle a effleuré les côtes.
Quelqu'un aurait un putain
de tampon ?
Oui...
Très serré, d'accord ?
Ils cassent les vitres !
Ils ont tiré sur le moteur !
Il faut appeler la police au 911.
Il n'y a pas de réseau.
Putain de Texas !
Il y a peut-être une radio
dans le car ?
Elle ne marche plus.
Merde !
Faut quitter cette route.
Si on s'arrête, on est morts !
Vous entendez ?
- Un embranchement !
- Peut-être qu'il y a une ville !
- Je ne vois aucune ville.
- On tourne à gauche ?
On quitte la route ?
Cette route-là,
c'était une mauvaise idée !
Tu préfères retourner là-bas ?
Et toi, tu veux que je t'expédie
par la fenêtre ?
Les amis vont bien s'occuper
de toi !
Rangez ça !
Il y en a trois,
qui arrivent sur la droite !
Je commence à attraper le coup.
- Il y a un portail.
- Défoncez-le !
Sortez du car !
Il est mort. Allez !
Vite !
Dans le bâtiment, vite !
Fermé.
Par ici !
Passez !
On est faits comme des rats !
C'est ça, foutez le camp !
C'est fermé !
C'est sans issue.
- Faut faire un barrage.
- La table !
- Dis, lapin...
- C'est Duke !
Surveille l'arrière.
Ils ont arrêté de tirer.
Venez par ici.
Aidez-moi !
Hé, l'entraîneur...
Quel est ton nom ?
Jerry Yarbro.
Il te reste combien de balles ?
Je peux voir ?
Vas-y. Elle est soldat.
Non, ça ne fait rien.
Le chargeur contient 13 balles.
Le type a tiré une fois sur lui,
une fois en l'air
et une fois sur toi.
- Il en reste donc dix.
- Il ne m'a pas tiré dessus.
- Si.
- Je te dis que non.
Regarde ton col.
Toi, tu as tiré quatre fois,
Jerry.
Tu as gâché 40% de munitions
et tu n'as touché personne.
Il nous a fait gagner du temps.
- Tu devrais me le donner.
- Essaye de t'en trouver un.
Ils s'en vont !
Peut-être parce que
vous leur avez tiré dessus.
C'est ça, fous le camp,
connard !
Les Nomades,
ce n'est pas leur genre.
- Alors, soldat ?
- Ce gars-là ne s'en va pas.
- Que fait-il, alors ?
- Il est parti chercher ses potes.
ITINERAIRE DES CARS
Donne-moi le tournevis.
Quoi ?
Non, rien.
Un téléphone.
Merde !
Ça va ?
Ouais, ça va...
Mis à part le fait, que...
l'on m'ait tiré dessus.
Parle-moi de ton fils.
Stevie, hein ?
Quel âge a-t-il ?
Il a quatre ans.
Et il aime... les armes à feu ?
Comme celle que tu as achetée ?
Ouais, il aime les...
En fait, je ne l'ai...
jamais vu.
J'sais pas.
T'as qu'à demander à tous ceux
qui m'ont donné un travail.
En tant que personne,
je... ne vaux rien.
Quand Carole...
est tombée enceinte, je...
- Tu as fui ?
- Ouais, très loin.
Mais tu y retournes
aujourd'hui ?
Carole aime les surprises
à Noël ?
Ouais, elle et son...
nouveau mari
savent que je viens et...
J'ai un petit cadeau
pour elle aussi.
- Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
- Je rentre au pays.
- Et ton nom ?
- Sam Cutter.
Meredith Cole.
Je ne peux même pas envoyer
de texto.
Ils restent là.
Qu'est-ce qu'ils font ?
J'ai un produit pour l'enlever.
Tiens.
Moi, c'est Maud.
Annabelle !
Regardez-les, à courir partout.
On dirait des cafards.
Baisse-toi, lapin.
Ils ne tirent pas sur les lumières,
c'est déjà ça.
Ils réservent leurs munitions
pour nous.
Je peux avoir la torche ?
- Merci.
- Surveille l'entrée.
Mon Dieu, je t'en supplie...
Ne me laisse pas mourir ici.
Désolée, je ne comprends pas.
Tu parles l'espagnol ?
Désolée, j'aurais dû l'apprendre
à l'école...
De la peinture...
Vous voulez ça ?
J'ignore ce que vous êtes
en train de faire, mais continuez.
- Tu pourrais nous aider.
- Tu voudrais que je t'aide ?
Quand tu construis
une barricade,
évite d'utiliser des trucs
qui risquent d'exploser.
Ça t'aide, ça ?
- Elle est énervée.
- Tu crois ?
T'es vachement perspicace
comme mec.
Tiens. Contre la douleur.
Merci.
Je l'ai eu !
Je crois que je l'ai eu !
Tu ne l'as pas eu.
Il est allé se planquer.
- Tout le monde est encore là ?
- Silence !
- Sam ?
- On est là.
L'entraîneur ?
Ouais, ça va.
- Lapin ?
- C'est bon.
- China ?
- Elle s'appelle Désirée.
La ferme, lapin !
Ça va.
Ils sont combien en tout ?
Regardez ce que j'ai découvert.
Une cachette.
Venez, on monte.
- C'est sinistre ici.
- Moi, ça m'inspire.
Sois prudente.
Là...
Qu'est-ce qu'ils font.
Tu vois ce vieux frigo ?
- Ils vont se mettre là, derrière.
- Comment tu sais ?
Moi, je m'y mettrais.
On est à l'abri,
ils font feu sur notre barricade
et ils lancent l'assaut.
Tu t'y connais en chasse ?
"Société d'Archerie
des Elfes Noirs".
- Quoi ?
- Je suis classée en archerie.
As-tu entendu parler
du "Mythe de l'Alliance" ?
Les conventions des jeux vidéo
et tout ça ?
Ces fêlés qui courent dans la forêt
habillés en moyenâgeux ?
On n'est pas très différents de
ces fêlés, qui se déguisent en soldats
sécessionnistes
et qui se tirent dessus...
En fait, j'allais en Californie
pour un Tournoi des Elfes Noirs...
Une compétition.
Donc... Le truc de l'Archerie,
c'est...
Oui, c'est du tir à l'arc.
Il est dans le car.
Et toi, tu es une Elfe Noire
classée ?
Oui... ça veut dire,
que je fais de la compétition,
pas que je tire sur des humains.
Une chose est sûre.
Ces gars n'ont rien d'humain.
Viens, on va chercher
ton matériel.
Ça va, mon pote ?
Désolé. Je te laisse tranquille.
Joyeux Noël.
Dis bonjour à l'autre foldingue
et à tous les fêlés du coin.
L'an prochain, Archie
mange de la dinde.
- Ils étaient combien ?
- Sept.
Qu'est-ce qu'ils faisaient ?
OK. Nous, on est là.
On n'a qu'à les appeler "Racaille",
"Gros Lard" et "Acrobate".
Ils sont à côté de cette grange.
La "Frisée" est là,
au milieu des frigidaires.
Ici "Barbu", "Grizzly" est celui qui
surveille la route depuis ici et...
Tu en oublies un...
"Cupidon". C'est bizarre
qu'il n'ait pas mis le feu.
Ils ont peur.
Le feu, ça se voit de loin.
Non. Ils attendent les autres.
- Ils veulent nous séparer.
- Tu les connais, ces connards ?
Un de mes ex était motard.
Il m'a dit, que ces Nomades,
c'était comme des sauterelles géantes.
La plupart se shootent
toute la journée au méthylène.
Ils s'installent dans un endroit
et en retirent tout ce qu'ils peuvent.
Nourriture, combustible,
argent, femmes...
Puis ils s'en vont.
Mon mec c'était un dur, un vrai.
Il avait peur de rien.
Mais ces Nomades...
lui foutaient la trouille.
Il faut nous défendre,
jusqu'à ce que l'aide arrive.
- Ils se fatigueront avant nous.
- Oui, quelqu'un viendra bien, non ?
Non. Picadillo devait être
notre prochain arrêt...
S'ils verront qu'on n'arrive pas,
ils enverront de l'aide.
Ecoutez-moi...
- On ne tiendra pas deux minutes.
- Tu préfères le car ?
Et finir comme l'étudiante
et le type chauve ?
C'est à cause de toi,
qu'on a choisi cette route !
- Bien, moi je dis...
- La ferme, bordel !
Désolée.
Mais Picadillo n'était pas
un arrêt officiel.
Ils croiront qu'on s'est arrêtés
ailleurs pour manger et prendre de l'essence.
C'est El Paso notre prochain
arrêt officiel, à 600 km au Sud.
Donc, ils ne s'inquièteront pas
avant six bonnes heures...
Et d'ici là, Cupidon et ses copains
seront revenus pour nous tuer.
Toi qui as de l'expérience,
qu'est-ce qu'on doit faire ?
C'est une gamine.
Elle a dû récurer les latrines.
Alors ?
Je te l'ai déjà dit.
Ne pas céder.
C'est quoi ?
Un souffleur de feuilles ?
Pauvre taré.
Qu'est-ce que tu as bien pu
lui trouver ?
Il me faisait rigoler.
C'était intentionnel ?
- Qu'est-ce que tu fais ?
- Rien...
Des gribouillis.
Je fais des caricatures
pour gagner un peu d'argent.
- De l'illustration.
- Je peux voir ?
- C'est rien... seulement...
- Vas-y, montre.
Non, ce n'est rien d'important.
Ce sont des gribouillages
sans queue, ni tête.
Une carte...
- Où est-ce qu'on est ? Ici ?
- Le trou du cul du Texas.
La prochaine ville
est à une centaine de km.
Non, attendez...
Il y a une route au Sud.
A 30 km d'ici à tout casser.
On devrait...
Tu veux que quelqu'un se tape
30 bornes dans cette campagne
avec une carte d'écolier ?
Si ça se trouve, il ne passe
une voiture qu'une fois par mois.
- Et qui doit aller courir ?
- Moi.
Je cours.
Le jogging entre l'école et le
supermarché, ça ne compte pas.
Je cours dans des marathons
contre le cancer du sein et la leucémie.
Dans la rue, avec des gens
sympas, qui vous donnent de l'eau.
Ici, c'est incompatible avec les
fanfreluches et les talons aiguilles.
Vous me prenez pour une idiote ?
Je le sais bien !
- On peut les battre.
- Non, on ne va pas les attendre.
Il faut aller chercher de l'aide
et j'y vais !
Je vous dis, que non !
Lâchez-moi !
Tu devrais te maîtriser, Jerry.
On peut les battre.
C'est ridicule.
Comment je vais faire
pour échapper à ce crétin ?
Non...
Non Sam, ce n'est pas
une bonne idée.
Je suis incapable de tirer
sur des personnes.
Je suis pacifiste, c'est...
Un arc et des flèches, Sam ?
Comme Robin des Bois.
Il n'avait pas affaire à une bande
de psychotiques shootés à l'acide.
Tu crois qu'Annabelle
peut y arriver ?
Elle peut toujours essayer.
La nana est toujours dehors ?
Non, elle est partie.
Allons, tu perds du temps.
Grouille-toi !
Sam, regarde autour de toi.
Fais attention !
Sam ! Arrête tes conneries !
Tu crois qu'ils m'ont vu ?
Quoi ?
Tu as montré à ces connards
comment on rentrait !
Tu nous mets en danger
et pourquoi ? Pour ça ?
Un talkie-walkie.
Ça peut nous être utile...
- Enfoiré !
- Ça suffit, vous deux !
Mon sac de voyage ?
Je me suis dit, qu'il y aurait
peut-être des choses intéressantes.
Il n'y a que des survêtements
et des affaires sales.
Tiens.
Pour quand tu sortiras.
Merci.
Il est vraiment fêlé, celui-là !
Je suis incapable de tuer
qui que ce soit.
Mais si, chérie.
Ne joue pas la princesse.
Bébé...
- Elles te vont ?
- Oui. Parfaitement, merci.
Qu'est-ce que tu fais dans un car,
le soir du réveillon ?
Je suis allée enterrer ma soeur.
Je suis mère célibataire
et je...
Je ne voulais pas que mes filles
voyagent juste avant les fêtes.
Heureusement, pour elles.
Ta soeur avait un cancer ?
Oui, ma soeur, maman...
Moi.
Cancer du sein.
Mes filles. Emma et Lucie.
- Elles sont mignonnes.
- Oui.
Tant que je cours...
Je suis tout ce qu'elles ont.
Tiens.
- Au cas où, tu sais ?
- Ouais.
Je comprends.
Quoi qu'il se passe,
ne t'arrête pas.
C'est ce que j'ai appris
en Irak.
Tu as dû en baver.
J'ai... une torche pour toi.
Merci. J'en aurais besoin.
Et... ça.
Au cas où je rencontrerai
des méchants ?
Non, il y a une boussole juste là.
- Tu sais lire une boussole ?
- Oui, j'ai été chez les scouts.
C'est pour toi.
Voilà, qui est galant !
Vous êtes pratiquant, Yarbro ?
Seulement les vendredis soirs.
A la mi-temps.
On est vendredi soir.
- Joyeux Noël.
- C'est "Gros-Bide", là ?
- Il est près du tracteur.
J'ai des chances de passer ?
Ouais, mais s'il t'attrape,
ils ne vont pas t'épargner.
Je l'ai dit à Sam,
je le dis à vous tous...
Je suis incapable de tuer
quelqu'un avec mes flèches.
C'est mal de tuer.
Mais, Annabelle, j'ai deux filles.
Il faut que je vive.
Ne me laisse pas mourir.
Il ne l'a pas encore vue.
Descends-le !
- Vas-y !
- Arrête !
- Descends-le !
- Qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
La princesse va laisser Maud
crever.
Dis-lui de le tuer.
Sam !
- Il y en a deux qui arrivent.
- Ils vont réussir à entrer !
Sam, attention !
C'est bon...
Maud va y arriver.
Vas-y, ma poule !
Merci.
Ça va...
Tu devais le faire.
Ça va aller.
Elle en a tué deux...
ça c'est sûr.
Je ne sais même pas,
si j'en ai eu un seul.
Il en reste quatre,
peut-être cinq.
Et ce...
ce motard sur la route, c'est le
premier que tu n'aies jamais...
Non.
Paraît que ça devient
plus facile.
Oui.
Chouette.
J'sais pas ce qu'ils font.
- Ils vont chercher Maud.
- Qu'est-ce qu'on fait ?
Rien. Elle trace.
Soit ils l'auront,
soit ils ne l'auront pas.
Eh ben,
tu n'es pas une tendre.
- Désirée !
- Mon Dieu !
On n'a qu'à la laisser
dans la camionnette.
Elle disait,
que tu la faisais rire.
Jamais, quand j'essayais.
- Ça faisait longtemps ?
- Trois jours.
C'est encore pire que si on
n'avait juste été des étrangers.
On voulait aller à Las Vegas.
Elle voulait devenir croupière
et moi...
Je voulais devenir chanteur
dans les mariages à l'église.
C'est bizarre... Je savais
que j'allais tout faire foirer.
Merci.
Encore en train de faire joujou ?
Ouais...
Mais c'est impressionnant.
Quoi ?
Tu le comprends ?
Ouais, enfin...
Je crois savoir ce qu'il fait.
C'est un canon à patates, non ?
Quelqu'un sait comment
on dit "patate" en espagnol ?
Un canon à patates ?
Je me rappelle que des gamins
en faisaient dans mon immeuble.
On met la patate dedans, puis
un produit inflammable et ça y est.
Des patates, et boum ?
Ça marcherait
avec de l'essence ?
Non, on utilisait...
De la laque à cheveux... oui.
Des flèches et un canon
à patates, c'est dingue...
Pourquoi pas un pistolet à eau ?
Non, tu peux tout mettre dans
ce machin. Des clous, des pierres...
Où va-t-on trouver de la laque ?
On n'en a pas besoin...
On a de l'éther.
C'est très inflammable.
C'était trop bas et trop à droite.
Visez plus haut, pour avoir les motos.
Saloperie de racaille !
Sauvage !
Viens.
- Suis-le.
- Et toi ?
Je sais où il va, ce connard.
Vas-y, envoie !
Stop ! Ne tire pas.
C'est bon, ils sont tous morts.
On a tenu, soldat.
Je ne peux pas mourir !
J'ai des enfants !
J'ai deux filles !
J'ai des filles !
Je suis désolée...
Hé, salopard !
J'ai besoin de ta voiture.
Les clés sont dedans.
- Combien de survivants ?
- Sept, quand je suis partie.
- Meredith Cole ?
- Blessée, mais c'est une dure.
- Vous la connaissez ?
- Je la poursuis.
Au bout de cette route,
tournez au sud.
Il y a une petite ville à 10 ou 20 km.
On trouvera de l'aide.
Ils seront morts,
quand les secours arriveront.
Oui, madame.
Comme vous voudrez.
Allons-y, on a pas mal
de km à faire.
- Ils sont combien ?
- Six, huit...
Peut-être plus...
- Cole, qu'est-ce que t'en dis ?
- Fuir.
Tu es blessée, soldat.
Tu ne ferais pas 200 mètres.
Pas moi. Vous.
J'ai besoin de la mitraillette
et de plusieurs Molotov.
- Non, on va...
- Partez.
Pour qu'ils nous traquent
et nous tuent un par un ?
- Jerry ?
- Je dis, qu'on reste.
Duke ?
Señor ?
- Annabelle ?
- D'accord pour en tuer 2 ou 3,
mais après, il faut que
les garçons tuent les autres.
Allons-y.
On se prépare.
Quoi ?
C'est ce que disaient les irakiens,
sur une route dangereuse.
"Qu'Allah soit loué, si je me sors
de ce merdier en un seul morceau".
A un de ces jours, Sam.
Tu sais, ton nom ?
J'ai pris ça sur le cadavre
de ces pourritures.
Vous avez fait des flèches ?
Connard !
On y va !
Crevez, sales cons !
Duke !
J'y vais, chef.
Putain de cons !
Jerry !
Hé, l'enfoiré !
Il fallait pas revenir !
J'espère que tu as encore
ton flingue.
Pour toi au moins,
tout est fini.
Accrochez-vous !
Mon Dieu !
Duke...
Trop tard.
Je suis arrivée trop tard.
Sam ? Ça va ?
Ça a effleuré ma tête.
On va sortir d'ici.
Salut, sergent.
M. Vargas est en traumatologie.
Ils sont optimistes...
"Vargas" est un joli nom.
Je suis désolée.
Le sergent ne m'avait pas dit
qu'il te poursuivait.
Ça ne fait rien.
C'est sans doute,
parce que tu l'as menacé.
Ces hôpitaux me donnent
le cafard.
- Veuillez attendre ici.
- Tes filles sont là.
N'oublie pas...
Ne jamais céder.
- Toi non plus.
- Merci.
Deux minutes, sergent.
C'est la fin de vos aventures.
J'ai parlé au docteur.
Ils veulent vous garder.
Mais vous avez l'air suffisamment
en forme pour pouvoir voyager.
Merci. J'en ai marre
de la nourriture des hôpitaux.
Vous serez menottée jusqu'à
Fort Bliss, où vous serez jugée.
Le caporal, cette femme
dont m'ont parlé les civils...
Ce n'est pas celle
que je connaissais.
Alors, vous leur avez dit,
ce qu'elle avait fait ?
La raison de votre désertion
ne me regarde pas.
Peut-être...
que le capitaine l'avait mérité.
Mais...
ce n'est pas à moi d'en décider.
Habillez-vous, caporal.
Il vous reste 20 minutes avant
l'arrivée de la voiture de Bliss.
Archie...
Joyeux Noël.
- Alors... Où est-ce qu'on va ?
- Maud nous attend.
Ne jamais céder.